we evolved as human beings a few million
years ago on the Savannah in Africa and
we evolved to escape tigers or Lions or
predators and so what makes common sense
to us is the world on our scale you know
how to throw a rock or a spear or how to
find a cave and and and we didn't evolve
to understand quantum mechanics and
therefore it's not too surprising that
on scales vastly different than the kind
of experience we had as we were evolving
as a species that nature seems strange
and sometimes almost unfathomable
certainly violates our common sense our
sense of what is common sense and what's
intuition but as I like to say the
universe doesn't care about our common
sense we have to force our ideas to
conform to the evidence of reality
rather than the other way around and if
reality seems strange that's okay in
fact that's what makes science so
wonderful it expands our minds because
it forces us to accept possibilities
which in advance we may never have
thought was possible I've said that
scientists love mysteries and we do
that's the reason I'm a scientist
because it's the puzzles of the universe
that make it so exciting now it is true
that we want to solve resolve those and
and solve those puzzles that's part of
the fun of doing Sciences is solving
puzzles basically but each time we do
what new questions arise and I think for
many of us just as in our lives the
searching is often much more profound
than the finding it's a searching for
answers through life in some sense that
make life worth living if we had all the
answers we could just sit back and stare
at our navels and I think what makes the
search so exciting is that the answers
are so surprising the universe continues
to surprise us in ways we never would
have imagined and well beyond our own
imagination in advance and that's why we
have to keep exploring the universe we
can't just sit in a room and think about
it because every time we open a new
window on the universe we're surprised
and that makes the whole process
incredibly exciting
you